quand vous entendez justement françois
fillon qui évoque la possibilité de
tabler sur 4 7% de déficit en 2017 c'est
irresponsable la seule chose que je peux
dire c'est que si on regarde l'évolution
des chiffres encore une fois je me base
sur les chiffres ces 2 9 % en 2017 et
c'est 3,1 pour cent la politique
inchangée donc sans effort d'économies
supplémentaires en 2018 et donc il
faudra pas faire le coup de l'héritage
ou du legs on peut décider des lacs à
2,7 pour cent mais si on décide d'aller
avec 1,7 pour cent ça veut dire qu'on
décide par soi même de faire une relance
budgétaire de l'ordre de 1,6 pour cent
et de s'abstraire totalement du règles
du pacte de stabilité et de croissance
évidemment ça crée en europe quelques
turbulences probablement